i stand squarely behind my decision
after 20 years
i've learned the hard way
that there was never a good time to
withdraw
u.s forces here's what i believe
to my core
it is wrong to order american troops
to step up when afghanistan's own
armed forces would not the incompetence
of the bite administration on this is is
really overwhelming there needs to be
resignations there needs to be firings
this makes all of us angry because it
was completely avoidable what happens in
afghanistan doesn't just stay in
afghanistan it spreads like a cancer
president biden speaking today and you
can see the fear obviously in the people
running away from those planes at the
kabbalah airport but you can also see it
on
the face and in the voice of one of the
reporters in the pentagon briefing today
a reporter an afghan woman who has been
covering the pentagon
but we'll go back to afghanistan take a
listen
afghan women didn't expect that
overnight all the taliban came
they took off my flag this is my flag
they put their flag where is my
president former president ghani he has
to fight
for us people i had a lot of achievement
i i left from the taliban like 20 years
ago now
we go back to the first step again
afghanistan's president ashraf ghani
left the country just to put a
cost on what the u.s has spent
in the total cost of the war
978 billion dollars from 2001
to 2020
not including obviously the blood and
treasure uh left there let's
bring in our panel senior political
analyst brit hume ben dominic publisher
of the federalist harold ford jr former
tennessee congressman ceo of empowerment
inclusion capital and trey gowdy former
congressman from south carolina brit
your thoughts on the president's speech
particularly and this day
well the president's speech was about
the one thing that he knows is still
popular and that is the idea of getting
out of afghanistan but for much of the
speech i couldn't figure out what war he
was what so-called war he was talking
about we've been getting out of
afghanistan gradually slowly for years
and years we were down now in that
country to about 2500 american soldiers
on the ground no american soldier had
been killed there in a year and a half
but that little modest force uh with the
air power the intelligence and the
logistical support and the advice that
came with it was enough to maintain a
kind of an uneasy stalemate in that
country the president comes along and
blows the whole thing up because he
wants to get out we were getting out
and it mattered how we got it it always
matters how you get out in a situation
like this withdrawals and evacuations
are very militarily tricky and dangerous
and this one has been utterly and
completely botched and apart from saying
that they didn't expect it would go
downhill this fast the president really
did nothing to explain how that happened
or why it has gone so badly
trey got it
yeah i mean we have a choice as it
relates to withdrawal it was either the
right policy wrongly executed or it's
the wrong policy wrongly executed but i
think everyone in the country agrees
this has been a debacle i keep thinking
of the words of robert gates not the
republican congressman we just played
but obama's former secretary of defense
who said joe biden for four decades
was wrong on nearly every major foreign
policy and national security decision
that's robert gates saying that four
decades worth
i'm happy he kept a campaign promise
because he seems really really
interested in doing that i'm just sorry
for all the carnage left behind because
he did it has been interesting to watch
the evolution of the week and
how this transpired very quickly take a
listen
this is not just about the overall idea
of leaving afghanistan this is about
leaving hastily and ineptly secretary
blinken how did president biden get this
so wrong so
was he
misled by his own intelligence agencies
did he not listen to them why why was he
so wrong about that mr biden who hasn't
been shy
about changing all sorts of other
policies he inherited from iran to
climate change why was he unwilling to
change this policy there's been an
implosion of u.s policy and i think
someone gets fired for this in my
opinion it would be secretary blanken
this is not the military's fault this is
an intelligence failure here in
washington
harold reaction all that
well first off thanks for having me look
i think
uh brett uh britain and trey are about
right uh in this sense uh president
biden uh declared to the country three
out of four americans agree with him
that america should not be in
afghanistan
any longer there's no doubt we
accomplished a lot of what we intended
to accomplish i was in congress
at 9 11.
we believe that a jihadist and al qaeda
were operating from afghanistan we sent
forces there to degrade them to kill bin
laden and we did
any time you project military
our american military into an engagement
would clear a clear objective or a
desired outcome they generally do very
very well
but you invite trouble and you invite
disappointment you invite undesired
outcomes
when the the defined purpose is not so
defined and over the last several years
it was not he had that right but without
question he being president biden but
without question they have botched this
exit
this national security team of his the
pressure is mounting in many many ways
for them to fix
uh this this exit plan for all of our
afghan allies but i would hope those of
us who wish to be critical of the
president and i don't wish to be
critical but those who wish to be
critical of him please not conflate the
two the exit from afghanistan is the
right thing to do we have other
priorities we need to focus on and if by
some chance afghanistan becomes a
woodstock for jihadists guess what we
will be able to marshal a coalition of
the willing a bigger stronger and
perhaps more resolute one than we did
under president bush if that indeed is
the case but they have to fix this exit
plan this will be president biden's
achilles heel if he does not you know we
didn't hear a lot about the rules of
engagement for those troops trying to
get all those people out we didn't hear
how long the air bridge really is going
to run
in the present speech and just in the
past few minutes ben
associated press u.s defense official
confirms taliban's sudden accumulation
of u.s supplied afghan equipment is
quote enormous
you know this is a travesty in so many
ways and i do think that
we have to separate the policy here from
the execution the policy is broadly
popular
and i heard the president come out and
defend the policy of leaving afghanistan
but it's a speech that he could have
given six months ago and it really
didn't wrestle with any of the actual
questions that people have over what
they've seen over the past several days
particularly as it relates to any kind
of confidence that we can have in our
military leadership and our intelligence
community that promised that something
like this was going to take months if it
happened and frankly we look back at
that press conference that the president
had where he was doing all this happy
talk about the idea that the the afghan
military was prepared that taliban
leadership was not a foregone conclusion
that he expected them uh to fight etc
and the question really becomes is that
what he really believed is that's what
he was being told
and why if if he was saying that then
does his attitude now seem to be well
the people you know who need to get out
they should have been getting out much
earlier they chose to stay there well
maybe they chose to stay there because
of the things they were hearing from the
commander-in-chief of the free world and
that's something that i think is only on
him he cannot put that on donald trump
he cannot put that on previous
administrations it is on him that he
chose to say that and it's on him that
it turned out not to be true all right
some more thoughts with the panel after
a quick break